good morning John so when you got a
friend or a family member who is sick it
is normal and good to want to do
something for those people and you
should and as I have become one of the
people who people want to do things for
I have thoughts on how to do that well
what to do and what to avoid and also
because I am just one person I asked on
Twitter and I got a lot of people
thousands of people who responded to me
to tell me what they've really
appreciated and what they haven't with
of course the caveat the different
people are different and they're going
to want different things like I got
people saying that they both appreciated
it didn't appreciate the same thing but
here's one thing that I think you should
avoid asking what you can do I know it's
very tempting but it almost feels I
don't know this isn't it but it almost
feels like you're saying that so you can
get out of actually doing something
because I'm not gonna ask for something
from you because that's not how most
people do also being sick is a lot of
work is a lot of Burden already it's a
lot of stress and now I'm trying to
think of things that you can do that's
more work well you can and should do is
think of what you can do and then ask if
that's a good thing like what do you
need from me feels like a burden but
what kind of Pringles are your favorite
that feels like a gift now what people
need is gonna be very different person
to person like sometimes people are
gonna be in like a financially difficult
spot and in those situations getting
like an expensive gift can actually feel
bad because I don't need an expensive
gift right now I need like gasoline to
get to my doctor's appointment and so
someone surprisingly the number one most
appreciated thing I heard about on
Twitter was meal delivery gift cards
people also talked about gas cards rides
and just meals like delivered meals that
people made for them but things to avoid
when it comes to making meals for people
include not asking what they would like
it's good to ask and be like would this
be good because people like different
things and also they might have
restrictions both in general but also
because of their illness also this is
going to be context dependent but
cleaning up a casserole dish or
Tupperware is work that some people
might not be able to do right now I have
appreciated it when it comes in a
disposable container well nobody likes
disposable containers but in this
situation even if you don't want it back
like I'm not gonna throw it away I'm
gonna clean it and I'm gonna be
exhausted afterwards these little
aluminum pins are amazing and they sell
them at the grocery store now when it
comes to more gifty type stuff obviously
you're gonna know your person better
than I do but for me the things that I
have appreciated most are things that
imply in their giving that I should be
focusing on myself and healing and
resting so yes blankets pillows but also
smaller things like bath bombs or soap
or tea or lotion somebody gave me an oil
from my bald head here's my bald head by
the way I mean I have a fine head shape
it turns out like it's a good head shape
I just have always had hair I I liked it
flowers are also nice but what I will
say is I had a lot of flowers in the
first week uh and so if you want to give
flowers here's what maybe you should do
is schedule on your phone like two
months later or three months after you
hear about it and then send flowers down
also there are some flowers and I didn't
know this but there are some flowers
that are like morning flowers don't give
white lilies to a person who is sick
it's basically saying like I'm thinking
about your funeral you also might know
that your person loves something in
particular like Turkish delight or
Pringles but when it comes to something
that somebody might feel bad ignoring
for a while or throwing away you do want
to ask because being sick can change
your relationship with food it can mean
that there are periods of time when you
can't enjoy food or certain foods that
you're not allowed to eat so always good
to ask but I was really quite shocked by
what I heard the most when it came to
what people want from other folks when
they are sick and not because I hadn't
experienced it I had experienced the
exact same feeling
but I thought I'm a weirdo but no by far
the most requested thing the thing that
people appreciated the most from other
people was the people it was just Ty was
just like hanging out like we want to
hang out jinx it can of course be very
stressful sometimes it can be very time
consuming other times it can be super
boring and isolated there is often not a
lot to do and sometimes I both am bored
and do not want to hang out like I feel
awful and I just want to lay around but
sometimes I feel good and I want a phone
call I want to talk I want to do
something not like a hike
unfortunately I hope I get there but not
a hike but like I do want to hang now
one of my favorite things is that you
can do some of this stuff together like
you can sort of contrive to be in your
friend or loved one's neighborhood if
they live in your town and then you'd be
like hey I'm at X coffee shop near your
house can I get you anything I'd love to
come by and hang out you're not dropping
in unannounced that avoid that because
look they might be like currently puking
like you don't want to knock on a door
of a person and you don't know if they
would like to see you come by right now
they might be busy but saying like hey
I'm at the Taco Shop can I bring you a
quesadilla and then also letting
yourself be a part of the package if
they'd like it is lovely and like this
is a wonderful thing to do for a person
who doesn't have an illness but even
better for someone who might be craving
a little bit of socialization and a lot
of cheese people said over and over
again they don't want surprise drop-ins
but they do want visits from people
whether that's on the phone at the
hospital or at home and they also said
that as their illness progressed these
check-ins and hangouts tend to get
further spaced out and less common and
so with all of this stuff I think it's
important to say like in the week that
everybody's hearing about the illness
for the first time there's going to be
probably plenty of folks reaching out
and and offering support but two months
in six months six years in there's a lot
less of that and so schedule that I am
like this and I I don't know if it's a
good thing or a bad thing but I consider
everything in my life to be a project
including like my relationship with my
son and my wife and my brother like I
like all these things are things that I
need to to work on to invest in to spend
time on and to schedule friendships
don't happen if they don't get invested
in so put it on the calendar do it every
two weeks have a thing that says send
this person funny tick tocks or ask them
if they want a phone call or tell them
that you want to bring them A coffee and
as for things to avoid when it comes to
this stuff unless you've been through
something pretty similar I would avoid
advice now people who have had Hodgkin's
lymphoma and they've been through abvd
which is my chemo regimen I want to talk
to them about their advice all day and
night because it's like suck on ice
chips during the pleiomycin like you're
not gonna know that tip unless you've
been through it talking to people who
have been through a cancer diagnosis and
treatment and you know recovery and real
apps and all the different things that
can happen with cancer has been great
it's been very helpful people who
haven't been through it I just like I
don't know that your advice matters that
much to me like I'm sorry when I hear
from a person who's had my chemo regimen
and they say you know weed helped me a
lot with the nausea I'm like oh okay
thank you that's that's interesting to
know when I hear that from somebody who
just smokes weed a lot I don't care and
one of the scariest things about being
sick
is thinking that you might not be doing
the right thing for your health it's so
scary and it's hot it's impossible to
know a hundred percent of course but
this is very hard not to obsess over and
hearing from people that you might love
or trust that you should be doing or
trying something else should be done
very carefully and also it should never
be done with the intent to sway someone
away from a treatment plan that they
have developed with their doctor and it
feels really bad and I think also is bad
to get a person into a place where they
might be questioning their current
treatment plan that they have worked out
with a person who knows more about this
than you and that's why they're the
doctor of oncology or whatever and that
was a lot of words for something that
you're probably not going to do anyway
like I just wanted to say it just in
case but it is a thing to avoid what
people mostly want is like the same
stuff they want to make jokes about
their kids they want to relive all the
grad school fun they want to talk about
submarine disaster and they want to hear
what's up with you like it's just normal
socialization it can always feel weird
when you are socializing with a person
who is in a different situation than you
I promise it will get normal immediately
once you start to do it yeah that
person's in a different situation than
you might be used to but it's just a
person you do not have to treat them
like they're a delicate flower you
should not treat them like you're
already mourning their loss you can but
you don't have to talk about their
illness and treatment like they will
talk about that the amount that they
want to and sometimes they'll want to
and sometimes they won't trust me I love
to complain about being sick and I would
love for you to let me do that and
honestly just remember one of the great
joys of life is hanging out with friends
and this is just an excuse to hang out
with a friend so just hang out with a
friend because you're here at this video
because you want to help somebody out
this is why you clicked on this right
and I'm telling you once you've had your
basic needs fulfilled what people need
more than anything else regardless of
their health
is people
John I'll see you on Tuesday